everyone had to learn how to fight
everyone had to get in shape it seems
unfair because will you played alley it
feels like you started and you took that
so seriously you really learn to fight
like Ally you had a head start
yeah no you know it was I thought I had
a head start and then I got on the set
with this this group of people and I'm
47 this year and the average age here is
is probably 12
I'm messing around with Joel and you
know it's like everybody everybody's
thinking out of Wally looking all strong
I was like you know I got it I got it
take my position right two weeks in I
tore my calf that you know the sound you
make with the sound of dog makes when
you step on his foot
yeah yeah is this right you were
sparring with a lot his guys were
sparring with each other you were
sparring with the ladies right don't ask
me why Conan but they they they put me
with the ladies and I fought Karin Fuuka
Hara who believe me can kick Hara let me
tell you Beryl will Delevingne you MA